IBM Cloud satellite and VMware the IBM I
system subscription and an extra chance
to pass your Cloud certification exam
all on this episode of IBM Tech now
what's up y'all my name is Ian and I am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
IBM technology
distributed cloud is becoming
increasingly important as Enterprises
and regulated Industries realize that
their data often must remain in a
specific location
I've been Cloud satellite allows you to
run modern public cloud services in
locations of your choosing while
managing the services from a single
control plane
we're excited to announce that we've
integrated vmware's industry-leading VM
and storage Management Solutions with
the born in the cloud managed services
from IBM Cloud satellite
IBM Cloud satellite on VMware is
pre-integrated out of the box with
VMware vsan storage delivering a fast
time to value for both your applications
and the manage cloud services supporting
them
this all means that together with VMware
we provide a modern cloud-native
application platform that enables you to
develop and deliver apps to production
at the speed of cloud while keeping data
local
to learn more about IBM Cloud satellite
on VMware check out the blog I've got
linked below
next up is a way that you can take
advantage of subscription-based it
solutions for ultimate flexibility more
and more businesses are starting to look
at options to flexibly consume their it
requirements rather than owning Hardware
storage and software in the traditional
sense
they want the ability to modify capacity
or feature sets for quicker access to
technology on demand
the IBM I system subscription is a
solution that helps small and mid-sized
businesses with the challenges of
operating maintaining it environments it
provides the latest power 10
processor-based Hardware which is
currently the power s1014
IBM I software and services to support
and assist in the operation of your
environment
the subscription is billed on an annual
basis making it infrastructure planning
a lot more consistent and if new
technology becomes available you can
upgrade to the latest and greatest at
your next subscription
to learn more about IBM I system
subscription hit the link below
to finish up things this episode we're
thrilled to offer you an extra chance to
pass your Cloud certification exam for
free we're doing this with a new program
from the IBM Center for cloud training
and Pearson VUE called second chance
if it's your first attempt at the cloud
certification you can purchase an exam
voucher with a free retake and use the
retake if necessary
you can also retake an exam that you've
tried and not passed before by using a
promotional code
the number of Second Chance program free
exams is limited so make sure you
register today see the link below to
register and use the promotional code
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now